she played college football at the
University of Texas where he set a
record for most interceptions thrown in
the Holiday Bowl he played five seasons
in the NFL with the Bucks Titans in
Broncos the Broncos really I don't
remember that he is arguably the second
or third best quarterback in his own
family depending on who you ask what he
lacks in spleen he makes up for in heart
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
keep in mind your microphones on to
throw the f-word out a few times on this
show I had the record for the most
interceptions the holiday ball yeah damn
I played pretty good that game too I
mean it was a little unlucky but okay
but you have to be good enough to throw
that many interceptions right I guess
yes I think what did I throw two or
three in that game hit three is four in
my record and the holiday ball that's
what it says on your head I don't even
remember that I must've wiped that out
of my memory let me pick up on something
that a caller just mentioned about
LeBron and when he goes to the finals
you know and then he loses we of course
knock him down a peg right brady goes to
a Super Bowl when he loses or what or is
there any comparison between LeBron the
number of times getting and playing for
a title and losing right and Brady
number times getting to a Super Bowl and
losing yeah I mean I don't know there's
such different sports I think that's
where I would start with that
conversation right Tom Brady yeah we
know he's gonna go down as the greatest
quarterback of all time certainly the
most decorated all of those things
LeBron okay yeah he's gotten to the
super I mean the India the NBA Finals so
many times but come on how many times
has he got there with teams that are
less than right I mean we say I mean I
don't know can you name some of the
starters out there that we got on this
team last year impressive what longish
done or what Thomas - oh well I think
what the Patriots have done as a team is
more impressive I will say that much and
LeBrons what he's done is amazing
but of course football to me is the
ultimate team sport you got the greatest
coach of all time he's had a lot of good
players around him
you see what his game-planning does to
help him out at this time - that's why
he can continue to play his arms great
but the pass protection nobody even
those what color his eyes are and in the
playoffs yeah I mean nobody's gotten
even that close to him so I just think
what the Patriots are doing as a team
and of course Brady is the the biggest
part of that with Belichick we'll never
see anything like it again it's like
it's beating Red Auerbach in the Boston
Celtics it's beating Vince Lombardi and
the Packers is Belichick okay when we
start looking at greatest coaches right
time right
you throw red are ba yeah John Wooden
right football wise you know Lombardi
but a shorter window there Paul Brown
was great like where does Belichick fit
I mean we can go back to Al Arbor with
the New York Islanders I mean if we want
to do that and Scotty Bowman these
tangles whatever but where's Bella check
ranked all-time in all you know coaching
levels III don't even really I think
it's one I mean hands down where are you
staying on that I think it's hard to
quantify it it's very hard but but I
think to do what he's done right for a
long period of time so there were there
were spots in between where they went a
long time without a Super Bowl I know
gosh they had a wait so long you're
right they did for between championships
yes so they waited what seven eight
years yeah maybe even more than yeah
maybe ten years it was so that's a long
time
so that's not a dynasty for those first
couple right and after that you know
then it I guess the dynasty talk but I'm
just trying to figure out it's so hard
to win in football even if you're in a
bad division yep it's a one-and-done
right whereas basketball you got to beat
them four times UCLA used to play a lot
of their games in the tournament in Los
Angeles at the time I think to do it in
football for this amount of time
yeah with free agency with salary caps
yes everything I I think it's as
impressive if not more impressive than
any other coaching feat I'm with you I
think that's exactly where I would have
explained it I mean yes just we're in
the era of the NFL where they truly made
the rules for everything to be equal
right I mean they're trying to make it
to where the league's more exciting when
we have
in teams in the Super Bowl every year
and we've known nothing of the 21st
century except the Patriots in the final
four or the final two or just the actual
final one there's so many things that go
into successful organizations I mean
Belichick is the master even in my 18
months working there I've never seen
anything like it
the whole the whole front office the
coaches it's one of the most cohesive
units in all of football like you guys
pay attention in the NFL and you always
hear a little you know skirmishes
between the front office and the
coaching staff because they don't agree
on a player or philosophy none of that
goes on in New England because what's
Brady like in the quarterback room I
mean he's like as normal as could be
and not that I was in the quarterback
room a whole lot with them like cuz I
wasn't even like officially allowed to
be in that room but Brady couldn't be a
better more humble good guy I mean he
truly is an awesome person and he's
willing to step in line just like
everybody's heard the stories about him
just like anybody else and that's what
that's what like that's why they can
take risks on players like Albert
Haynesworth or let's say a Chad
Ochocinco where we look at it we go
Corey you and Corey Dillon right they're
gonna take them on yeah because when you
walk into the building in New England
you go damn they don't need me here
they're gonna be good without me no
matter what and if they can yell at Tom
Brady and you know mother f him for this
and that then damn they can eat I got
close but I didn't do it but but yeah
that's that's what puts you in line in
New England right away to go it takes a
self self aspect out of it now how long
were you with the Patriots I think was
18 months okay yeah at any point did you
were you told or did you witness where
you thought that they were pushing the
limits on scouting a team getting ready
for a team no never I've never been
around a place that followed the rules
more I mean I'm dead serious if Bill
caught wind that we were gonna bet five
dollars on the Masters who's gonna win
the golf tournament like there wasn't be
a cease and desist letter throughout the
building like no joke
there's no gambling on NFL we can't like
I mean though that's how rule-follower
they are they just I think one of the
dirty secrets and I try to sell some of
my coach friends around the NFL this at
times and they never want to ask me a
follow up after they ask me one question
with New England
but one of the dirty secrets of New
England is that their coach is just
out-compete the other coaches and I
don't mean to say that to knock down
anybody else in football but Bill's in
there grinding on May 7th the same he
was on January 7th I mean we had to have
a coach get up and raise his hands and
be like hey tomorrow's Mother's Day
coach and then he was like he had no
idea so that's just where he is in his
mind and I think at the end of a season
one of the reasons of course the
Patriots are winning or at the top of
the league is because their coaches have
won the competition between the other
coaches and put it a thousand more
man-hours when all said and done when
you match somebody like Shawn mikvah
yeah against Bill Belichick and he can
do that that's why I like John I mean he
can compete with them on that you know
work ethic Department sorry I didn't
mean to cut you off but just know I'm
curious about that that you have
somebody half the age right how would I
mean that's a would seem like a total
mismatch much more of a mismatch Shawn
McVeigh Bill Belichick Jared Goff Tom
Brady ooh that's a really good one I'm
gonna go I'm gonna say the bigger
mismatch is Brady golf right now but
it's really cool it's like McVeigh is
kid genius and there's obviously nothing
that you know he doesn't know everything
that that bill does but I do think
there's a lot of similarities until like
like Bill Sean doesn't he's not an
egomaniac like he is willing to listen
to ideas steel plays from other people
whatever it may be he's always trying to
acquire knowledge and that's the one
thing I really learned from Bill when I
was up there not that he taught me this
directly but I realized Bill is like
always looking for the new thing Chip
Kelly was up in our building a bunch of
times because he wanted to know how are
you getting these guys at Oregon at the
line of scrimmage so quickly and calling
these plays and running them so quick
Tom Thibodeau was in the building
because he was gonna he wanted to steal
something from him and I think McVeigh
is the same way like wait that shows it
an NBA coach yeah was there right I
think they want to witness Bella check
with Bella checks and they get something
out of the deal too all right we do this
every Super Bowl where we get draft
profiles if you're you mean you give
your host horrible like auction that was
a bad introduction I've had better oh
you okay this is when you were coming
out of Texas
okay this was your draft profile Oh from
Hill I mean now Holly do we know who
we just got we cobbled together most of
the negative yeah we cut out all the
positive I can give you the names after
the second okay are you ready yeah go
ahead and read your draft profile needs
to work on his accuracy okay Scouts
question his ability in big games
because he hadn't come up big against
top teams in the country hey true we
lost Oklahoma it was me versus Oklahoma
so just then that's nobody else is out
there no coaches no team it's just me
versus that just keep reading up sorry I
gotta throw some me toe has first-round
ability but his failure to come up in
the big games particularly against
Oklahoma led some to question stuff and
I was supposed to block Roy Williams
when he jumped over this pile and throw
it and catch it you know that okay 0
touchdown passes 14 interceptions in
games against the top 10 that hurts but
that's a fact yes okay his delivery is a
little slow at times and I think he's a
little too slow finding stuff over the
middle that's why you get the turnovers
I think that could extend into this
league he had a flawed college career
yes I was the top rated passer in the
big 12 for three years in a row and in
the top five twice but although he's a
great kid he's very blond hmm very fair
the tampa shouldn't have drafted me for
that all the sunday table and he still
and he stills are still a lot of
maturity ahead of him to me that means
he's not ready by a long shot
okay I'm who is this person okay this is
an actual quote there yeah although he's
a great kid he's very blond
yes that's he's very like what the hell
does that mean quarterback I don't know
but you know that's scouts it can be
biased in their own little way okay were
you helped or hurt by your dad being a
great quarterback
oh I mean I think in the long run I was
probably helped I mean uh you know
certainly invites criticism and people I
I mean still to this day I mean people
think I'm only on TV or talk because
your dad got you that job that's you
know I always hear that you know what
you're better than your dad thanks a lot
I appreciate that you are thanks no you
thanks but you know the football aspect
I would be lying hey I grew up I
relished the fact that I would walk into
a gym in sixth grade and I could hear
their sounds good and I would be like
you know I'm gonna show them that I have
to
since kid I'm gonna try score 30 points
tonight and I kind of like like this
stage of that so I think when I was one
of the best quarterbacks in the country
coming out of high school going into
college
I'm sure the Sims name helped me out and
gave me a little more notoriety I don't
think there's any denying that remember
your first time you met Bill Belichick
uh I do I mean I don't know if it was
the first time but my memories of Bill
are just like when I'm like an eight and
nine year old kid with the New York
Giants and really just him saying hi and
whatever else like nothing special there
was no like huge moment yeah yeah I
remember a Super Bowl 25 right after
they had won that against the bills you
know it was a weird Super Bowl cuz my
dad didn't play so I had like mixed
emotions or I was happy for the Giants
was sad my dad wasn't there you know and
I could still remember being after at
the after party and Bill and Lawrence
Taylor being in a booth and like that's
just a very vivid memory for me that guy
who just you know went up to them
because I wanted to say hi to both them
they're awesome and yeah whatever but
that's just one of my early
recollections we love you coming by your
great sport and I meant what I said a
great respect for your father but you
have carved out a great career a great
story I appreciate that
during the I know you're a little fired
up a little angry you want to take out
your frustrations yeah who brought
Hoover all day who is it who's we do you
want to tell him who wrote those things
I I cultivate I curated that list but I
can't really catch McLovin will stand in
for me do you want to tell him who wrote
those things I I don't but I mean it's
become a tradition for quarterbacks I
throw me this would be a good warm-up to
have a soft tossing lefty so for the
other cubies later in the week soft toss
and Lefty him being bandaged up all week
would be good content for the show right
yeah his play bortles coming in to throw
at me has he's taken on the best
quarterbacks in the NFL yeah Montana
he'd Aaron Rodgers right Eli I mean
there was a long list and he makes fun
of him before they start to tell you
he threw a bullet yeah that I said if it
hit McLovin in the heart he would have
killed I mean I've never seen anybody
throw the ball like Aaron Rodgers
through hard night
so if you're watching you'll be able to
see McLovin take his life into his own
hands here
well kind of yeah I mean it is a soft I
pretend I'm one of the defensive backs
in the 2007 Holiday Bowl Wow
who throws harder Jamie Moyer or Chris
Hill laugh at that
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]